the jogan experience you were telling me
you were a Bigfoot guy big Bigfoot guy
tell me about this here's the problem
when you grew up in an area yeah you're
in the Pacific Northwest that's Bigfoot
country that is I think that's the only
reason I'm so into it yeah also here's
the thing you got to know about talking
about M it's not ever funny and it's not
it's just it's something I like so much
that it ends up me giving you the same
arguments you've heard a billion times
yes oh it's gigant epicus came over the
Asian plane it's a bipedal homin it it's
just you know uh and then at the end and
everyone of my friends have experienced
it Haron Williams just experienced it
when I was on his podcast anytime I talk
about Bigfoot it ends up with me just
going please Joe can you just say it's
maybe a possibility like that's what it
always ends up being yeah you said it's
I I remember you one time going there's
nothing out there yeah didn't you say
that about hunters don't see it that's
why I don't believe in it some Hunters
do no not many people that see it are
usually loggers Hunters people that are
out there's another problem another
problem is dusk you see things at dusk
or at dawn it's very confusing Bears
walk on two legs all the time I have
personally watched Bears walk on two
legs and if I didn't know any better and
if it was a a dark environment like it
was dusk you know you like barely can
see I would think it's Bigfoot right
yeah but I do think Bigfoot existed
there there's some insane number of
Native American words for Bigfoot
Sasquatch is just one of them there's a
bunch of them there's a bunch of Native
American words for this one animal
that's fake but all the other words they
have are for real animals they don't
have a bunch of dragons they don't have
like mythical creatures in Native
American mythology but they do have this
one giant man thing that definitely
existed at some point at 100%
gigantopithecus was was a real animal it
was 8 to 10 ft tall bipedal homed it was
a huge gorilla looking primate that died
off somewhere around 100,000 years ago
but they don't know really sure, yeah
but they don't know for sure the thing
about it is it's like if you only find
fossils from 100,000 years ago you could
assume that that's that this animal at
least lived then but you don't know when
it went extinct right you might find
some new fossil like 10 years from now
they might from find some new sight and
wait a minute these These are 20,000
years old or these are 30,000 years old
or these are 50,000 years old but we
either way an anatomically identical
human beings have been around for
500,000 plus years maybe even more so or
similar human beings so then we
definitely interacted with them yeah or
they were around when we were around I
think they're still around I think
there's hundreds maybe thousands of them
that's what I believe I think they're in
caves or something or maybe it's you
know what the problem with that is what
they're too big the the amount of food
that they would need to eat yeah You'
have to be grazing all day long see if
you're Bigfoot posted in The Zo Journal
of zoology this month if it's there
could it be a bear they're saying it's
black bear American black bear yeah
American black bear that stands up but
he's even little kids would know the
difference between a monkey and a bear
no no no no no no first of all let me
tell you something um if you're in the
woods and you're on in a heightened
state looking around you don't know
what's out there it's all thick Woods
it's weird weird Woods are weird and you
see something you could trick your brain
I saw a squirrel and for like two or
three seconds I thought it was a wolf
really yeah yeah WF it's real between
here I'm seeing something moving in
between thick trees and I see gray fur
I'm like oh my God is that a wolf yeah
cuz there's wolves out there right it
was I'm in Canada I'm like oh it's a
squirrel what the is wrong
with me what the is wrong with me
shoot it yeah it's like people see what
they want to see and the problem is you
get something into someone's head a
mythological thing whether it's a UFO or
whether it's Bigfoot I think it's I
think the world is way more slippery
than we like to think and I think
there's States Of Consciousness that
people can achieve during high anxiety
levels definitely during the use of
psychedelic drugs yes sometime during
weird States in their life like
near-death experiences loss of a loved
one extreme emotion a lot going on a lot
of anxiety and fear like you would have
if you're in the woods sure and then you
see you see a light across the sky it
might have been just a meteorite right
but you're in the wrong headp space to
see that meteorite and you just
you just freak you just freak and maybe
for a brief moment you can see something
that's been there all along you know how
defeated I am right now I just want you
to tell me like dude there's some crazy
some crazy stuff out there I've uh
interviewed a lot of Bigfoot people I
had one bit joke I used to do about
Bigfoot here's what you don't find when
you go looking for bigfoot black people
you're more likely to find Bigfoot that
you are black people looking for big
it's a bunch of unfuckable white guys
out camping that's like that is a thing
it's a community of people that want to
believe something that there's zero
evidence for and they're locked
in yeah they're hitting a tree with a
stick going like we're going to wait for
a knock back and it's different Bigfoot
researchers hitting a different tree
talking back to them yeah it's like if
you go to public land elk hunting
there's a bunch of people elk calling
you think elk it's a dude with guy elk
two men doing elk calls exactly to each
other literally happens I bet it does
100% it's one of those things where I
wish it was real I wish big was Bobcat
goldway believes yeah he loves it he's
all in did you ever watch Willow Creek I
didn't piss me off because at the end it
just it turns out to be I'm going to
spoil a Willow Creek but at the end it's
just a bunch of like Hillbillies out
there killing and blaming it on Bigfoot
basically that's like the the end is
likeit which one are you talking about
you's I think that's what the end is
that like it's just some crazy people
that live in the woods it's not really a
Bigfoot is that true I think that's the
end of Willow Creek I don't remember how
it ends because they kind of have this
one kind of like Blair Witch like shot
and it's just a bunch of H you know
mountain people which is the scariest
thing you'll find in the woods people
well that's that U people that want to
be off that grid people that's that
documentary Sasquatch do you ever see
that it's like a documentary Series yeah
and it turns out just to be the cartel
blame oh not the cartel but like we we
people weed people killing other blaming
it on a big foot framing it to look like
a Bigfoot's out there yeah yeah they
killed somebody and that apparently when
marijuana
was you know when they were growing it
up there these hippies started arming
themselves you know and then they had
rival gang wars with people that would
come in and try to steal their crop and
so they started shooting at each other
killing each other yeah that's what
that's all about we're also like you
know some cute girl that's like oh I'm
going to clip weed all summer and make
five grand and hang out with other
potheads who like you don't realize how
terrible that job is well you're you're
involved in illegal business and the
cartel's in that business like I had a
friend who found a cartel grow operation
on a ranch yeah they were they were he
works on a ranch in California and he
was doing his thing out in the ranch and
he found some uh water piping and uh he
followed the water piping and you know
was pretty considerable distance and
they found this growop so this guy had
diverted water or many guys they didn't
see the humans that did it they took
their and then they never caught
the guys I don't think but they would
set up these camps in like uh they would
go to like national forests apparently
it's big in Northern California where
they go deep deep deep in the woods they
back back in and then they have a
massive grow up in on public land and
they just get it till the time it's you
know ready to harvest and and then they
get out of there but if someone
interrupts that if they get in the
middle of that they'll they'll kill them
right like these are cartel guys so my
friend John Norris he's been on the
podcast before he was a game
warden and he found a creek that had
been redirected and he thought like
maybe a farmer had did this like what's
going on maybe someone put an illegal
Dam on this they follow it and they find
this crazy grow up with the cartel and
guns and so he winds up instead of just
being a game warden now all of a sudden
he's got a tactical team with the tack
dogs and and they're they're running in
fully armed with Flack jackets on having
gunfights with the cartel in the woods
over weed yeah I will say that that's
like the most frustrating part about the
Bigfoot subject is you got guys like who
really like no I think an ape could like
a fam a pot of Apes could like live out
here and this thing and so you'll start
to Guys Like Me will be like yeah this
makes good sense and then they'll get
like a Native American to talk about it
and he'll be like it's the Magic Man of
the woods you're like no and like he he
disappears he flies you can stop the
rain and you go this is gosh dang it we
were making real good ground here making
Arguments for it to be an ape I think
the Native Americans are
right I think that's what it is some
sort of paranormal Woods thing yeah I do
I think it's
like listen if UF let's let's imagine
that States Of Consciousness can
interface with other things that are
around us all the time that we don't
necessarily see now we know that's true
if you take psychedelics and we know
that psychedelics are produced in the
brain I can imagine a
moment where you are in such a state
that you could see something that you
would not be able to see under normal
conditions it doesn't it's not outside
the realm of possibility I'm not married
to it but it's not outside the realm of
possibility now if that is what we're
seeing with with UFOs if what we're
seeing is our future is if what we're
seeing with those beings is the eventual
shape that human beings will take as
Evolution progresses we become these
genderless little spindly things giant
heads yeah flying spaceships with our
minds that kind of makes sense to me if
that makes sense why wouldn't I be able
to also see what we used to be or what
we could have been or what what other
things used to live with us and maybe
it's almost like a ghost almost like a
memory that you can access of a
different timeline a different dimension
where this thing does exist and that's
why it's so Elusive and it comes and
goes because it's not a real material
thing it's a construct of the human
psyche but these people that are seeing
it like they might even literally be
seeing Footprints it might literally
leave footprint it might exist for brief
moments makes passing in and out of this
Dimension kind of thing there's so many
wacky stories about it so then you have
to apply the wacky stories to human
psychology and say okay people are in a
heightened state they're in the woods
they're alone they're nervous there's
cats out there and Bears ah so
you're kind of freaking out already so
the you're in this like weird mind State
already where it seems like more things
are possible out there because there's
no one to help you right there's no City
there's no hospital can't call the cops
on a big flot you got no cell
phone signal and you're out there alone
like there's so many possibilities it's
terrifying and that to me makes sense
like if there's a mindset that could be
achieved it's a mind state that be
achieved where you interact with things
that aren't there all the time like UFOs
that would be when it would happen right
well there's tons of like interesting
stories that you'll just read about like
a thing just walking behind the tree and
it's not but if it was a massive yeah 10
foot thing you know you'd probably be
able to see it come out on the other
side of that tree and you see a lot of
those kind of or you read I read a lot
of those kind of stories and like I
don't know heck that yeah it could be
that but it could also be black bears it
could be that you're just seeing things
cuz they're freaking out yeah Bears
freak you out man you see a bear in the
wild it freaks you out and if you see a
bear in between trees oh yeah you can
just convince yourself that it's
something then your brain plays tricks
on you the memory is a slippery
yeah I know especially under heightened
circumstances like that like in the
woods your memory is weird and it's more
exciting to believe that it's real so
that's what you wanna you know that's my
biggest I think what I'm holding on to
so much is that like I think it's so
boring if we just know all the stuff on
our planet I don't think we do but
that's my point it's way more exciting
to think yeah there's bigfoots and
there's yeah pterodactyls is one of my
favorites wolf wolfman or dog men or
Moth Man or any of these kind of like
exciting things I I'm I want to believe
that well you know about that uh Hobbit
man that they found on that island of
Flores no no h man yeah this is a good
one for you um this is a thing that
absolutely live lived alongside people
and I think they they don't know the the
timeline of this either but they
think it might have been as recently as
like 50,000 30,000 years ago and they
were little tiny people three foot tall
like almost like aplike creatures that's
what they look like yeah see like a
little baby big well like like little
Hobbits man and they lived on this
island and they were like a different
brand of the human chain that lived
alongside Homo sapiens yes you see that
you just think you see a juvenile
Bigfoot or something yeah well there's
people that have cited these things in
other parts of the world still to this
day they still claim that they
exist